RIGHT NOW IT IS TIME TO PLAY
PAUSE FACE. PAUSE FACE.
(CHEERING)
>> I LOVE THIS GAME.
I LOVE THIS GAME.
IT'S MY FAVORITE GAME.
>> HARDWICK: THE ADVENT OF THE
DVR HAS MADE MANY THINGS
POSSIBLE, LIKE YOU WATCHING THIS
SH... RI... NOW... WI... IT...
DU... W...
(LAUGHTER)
...ALLOWING YOU TO SEE WEIRD
FACES YOU MIGHT OTHERWISE MISS
BECA... THEY... HA... TOO...
FAST... FOR YOUR EYES.
THANKS TO THE PAUSE BUTTON,
AWKWARD-- A BUNCH OF STONED
PEOPLE ARE LIKE, "WHAT THE
[BLEEP] IS HAPPENING?"
(LAUGHTER)
>> I... I AT ONE POINT WAS LIKE,
"WHAT IS HAPPENING?"
(LAUGHTER)
THANKS TO THE PAUSE BUTTON,
AWKWARD LIVE MOMENTS ARE NOW
PRESERVED FOR POSTERITY.
THE INTERNET HAS DUBBED THIS
PHENOMENON "PAUSE FACE."
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU A
DVR-CAPTURED PAUSE FACE.
FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT YOU TO
TELL ME WHAT THE FACE-EE IS
THINKING.
FIRST UP-- INTERCEPTION MACHINE
JAY CUTLER.
(LAUGHTER)
BRANDON JOHNSON.
>> I'M-A NEED A NEW CHIN 'CAUSE
MY STRAP BROKE.
>> HARDWICK: OKAY.
POINTS.
UH... KATE.
>> UH, I WEAR A NUMBER NINE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE.
HOW ABOUT HUMAN RANCH DRESSING
STAIN GUY FIERI.
(AUDIENCE GROANING, LAUGHTER)
>> HARDWICK: "MUMBLES"!
>> AND IN BRACKETS.
>> HARDWICK: YEAH. THAT PRETTY
MUCH WORKS FOR ANY GUY FIERI
SHOW.
UH, WHAT'S HE... WHAT'S HE
THINKING THERE? T.J.
(LAUGHTER)
MY FATHER DOESN'T LOVE ME 'CAUSE
I EAT FRIED BULL[BLEEP] FOR A
LIVING!
MY... MY HAIR LOOKS LIKE LADY
GAGA [BLEEP] A GOATEE.
>> HARDWICK: THAT'S DEFINITELY
WHAT... YOU SEE.
POINTS.
>> AND BRACKET.
>> HARDWICK: NEXT ONE...
IS THE GUY THAT'S PERFECT FOR
THIS, ALWAYS-- NICOLAS "PAUSE
FACE" CAGE.
(BELL DINGS)
BRANDON JOHNSON.
>> THIS DICK AIN'T GONNA [BLEEP]
ITSELF.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
KATE.
>> I HAVEN'T SLEPT SINCE CON
AIR.
>> HARDWICK: POINTS.
POINTS.